we recently did the story about Trish
Regan who's a host on Fox Business
Network and she is has been clearly
opposed to the Donald Trump tax bill
that recently passed and more broadly
we've talked before about the occasional
voices of reason on Fox News Shepard
Smith and sometimes chris wallace and
the big picture line on fox news has
been that there's nothing to the russia
investigation they pretend that there is
nothing there beyond a partisan witch
hunt by republican robert muller against
Republican Donald Trump I guess is what
they want us to believe Sean Hannity
totally in the tank against Muller that
wacky judge Jeanine Jeanine Pirro
straight up off her rocker recently said
there's a criminal cabal in the FBI that
is this investigation the problem isn't
the Trump campaign or the administration
it's the fact that Robert Muller is
investigating them and then we have
others like Lou Dobbs and Gregg Jarrett
on Fox and Fox Business who work really
hard I mean they're really putting in a
day's work to try to discredit the
entire investigation and pretend that
just nothing is going on so this morning
I saw a headline saying to Fox News
hosts slam their own networks coverage
of Trump Russia and I knew I knew right
away one of them has to be Shepard Smith
and it was Shepard Smith recently
interviewed Fox News resident Judge
Andrew Napolitano who very often is also
completely off his rocker
but Napolitano told it like it is
Shepard Smith set him up to do it and
straight up he said listen Kushner is in
the line of fire in this investigation
Trump jr. is in the line of fire and
Trump himself is in the line of fire and
our colleagues at Fox aren't being
upfront
take a listen take a look at this video
we know what's public but we don't have
a real idea of what the 17 attorneys
working for robert muller have have
learned have confirmed we we do not but
we know that the advice that the
president's lawyers gave him in August
this will be over by Thanksgiving is
absolutely untrue here it is Christmas
and it's ratcheting up we also know that
there have been no denials to the
Washington Post reports this morning
that this is likely to go through 2008
team and we also know that Bob Muller
and team are meeting with the
president's lawyers at the end of this
week we don't know what they're going to
say who based on the evidence based on
what's happened who's in the line of
fire now Jared Kushner jared krishna's
in the line of fire donald trump juniors
in the line of fire and of course the
president's in the line of fire we don't
know what Bob Muller has I am critical
of a lot of our colleagues who say
there's no there there
you know what Shep this is a jigsaw
puzzle with a hundred thousand pieces
and we see a piece here and a piece
there and everybody that doesn't make
any sense they're not connected it takes
time to amass all these evidence all
these pieces of evidence so that we see
the jigsaw puzzle completed and that's
what Muller and company are trying to do
indictments and and confessions yes yes
yes look general Flynn was exposed to 60
years in jail he had been convicted of
every charge that was out there and even
sentenced to the max he's now exposed to
six months how did he go from 60 years
down to six months he must have given
them something we won't find out what
that is until we get to that point in
the investigation but they know Bob
Muller knows we don't yes that's nice to
see a pleasure
none of this is controversial right the
only controversial part is that you
don't hear this on Fox News but this is
just a basic sober legal analysis here
it's clear that Kushner and Trump jr.
earned the line of fire by definition
this goes up to and possibly includes
the President of the United States
depending on what they find the truth on
Fox News is in a way more powerful
because it's just a never-ending Canyon
of BS the the problem is that because of
how the news cycle works I don't even
know how effective it'll be on their own
viewers uranium one is one example and
we talked about this pad on Fox News you
heard widespread promotion on critical
promotion of the uranium one conspiracy
theory for weeks and their viewers
bought it hook line and sinker and then
weeks in Shepard Smith does one segment
really good segment one segment
debunking the entire thing in about five
minutes but by then too much of their
audience the people that need to see it
already believe the conspiracy theory so
they see Shep and a half of them write
it off because Shep's gay
and he can't be trusted as the gay
liberal on fox news but i think
sometimes it's almost too late because
they're at this point preaching to the
converted already but the converted not
to their religion so to speak well well
maybe the Fox News viewers will see
their network as more credible right
because then they can point to people
like Sean Hannity and judge Jeanine
Pirro on the right and then they have
Shepard Smith and Andrew Napolitano on
the left so there's a whole diversity of
opinions maybe yeah but they'll still
only believe what they hear from the
Hannity and the Piro and whoever they'll
see FoxNews as a credible source
oh yeah that's dangerous that is
dangerous any anything that makes them
actually believe that Fox News is fair
and balanced which by the way they're
not they're no longer using that slogan
in terms of just to touch on one of the
things in the Politan Oh mention how
long the investigation will last
remember that the goal posts are now in
the parking lot it was first going to
wrap up within months of Trump's
inauguration then it was going to wrap
up by Thanksgiving then it was going to
be done by the end of 2017 and at this
point I cannot imagine that it ends
during 2018 and based on what we hear
publicly about where Moeller is it seems
to me that this is getting started
still not wrapping up and we'll see how
long it ultimately lasts the video you
just watched was made possible by
support from you please go to
patreon.com slash david pakman show you
can make a pledge of as little as $1 per
month and every dollar helps to support
the work that we're doing particularly
in light of the YouTube ad boycott which
has been really bad